[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de métropole et
d'outre-mer de l'étranger ce soir c'est
avec au coeur l'amour et la fierté de la
france que je me présente devant vous la
france est une nation ardente et
indépendante
la france c'est une nation engagée pour
la justice et pour la paix c'est une
voix qui s'élèvent au dessus des
intérêts particuliers
la france mes chers compatriotes je
laime passionnément
j'ai mis tout mon coeur toute mon
énergie et toute ma force à son service
à votre service servir la france
servir la paix c'est l'engagement de
toute ma vie j'aurai voulu bien sûr
bousculer davantage les conservatismes
et les égoïsmes pour répondre plus vite
aux difficultés que connaissent certains
d'entre vous mais je suis fier du
travail que nous avons accompli ensemble
fiers d'avoir restauré avec vous des
valeurs républicaines essentiels comme
le principe de laïcité fier d'avoir
conduit des réformes importantes pour
garantir nos retraites ou mieux aider
les personnes âgées dépendantes et des
personnes handicapées
fier d'avoir combattu sans relâche
l'insécurité et fait reculer la
délinquance fier de voir les françaises
et les français engagés sur les chemins
de l'innovation et de l'avenir
fier surtout d'avoir montré que contre
le chômage
il n'y avait pas de fatalité même s'il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin
le chômage est au plus bas depuis un
quart de siècle
la france tient son rang la france
affirme sa place dans le monde et tout
cela c'est grâce à vous grâce à votre
talent grâce à votre créativité grâce
aussi et je le mesure bien aux efforts
considérables que vous avez consentis
mes chers compatriotes au terme du
mandat que vous m'avez confié le moment
sera venu pour moi de vous servir
autrement je ne solliciterai pas vos
suffrages pour un nouveau mandat d'une
manière différente mais avec un
enthousiasme intact et la même passion
d'agir pour vous je continuerai à mener
les combats qui sont les nôtres
les combats de toute ma vie pour la
justice pour le progrès pour la paix
pour la grandeur de la france s'agissant
des échéances électorales
j'aurai l'occasion d'exprimer mes choix
personnels
mais ce soir et au nom de la confiance
que vous m'avez témoignée
je voudrais vous adressé plusieurs
messages
d'abord ne composait jamais avec
l'extrémisme le racisme l'antisémitisme
ou le rejet de l'autre dans notre
histoire
l'extrémisme a déjà failli nous conduire
à la bim
c'est un poison il divise il pervertit
il détruit tout dans l'âme de la france
dit non à l'extrémisme
le vrai combat de la france le beau
combat de la france c'est celui de
l'unité c'est celui de la cohésion
oui nos valeurs ont un sens oui la
france est riche de sa diversité
oui l'honneur de la politique c'est
d'agir d'abord pour l'égalité des
chances c'est de permettre à chacun à
chaque jeune d'avoir sa chance ce combat
malgré tous les obstacles et même si je
mesure le chemin qui reste à parcourir
il est désormais bien engagée il doit
nous unir d'hommes la durée
c'est l'une des clés de notre avenir mon
deuxième message c'est que vous devez
toujours croire en vous et en la france
nous avons tant d'atouts nous ne devons
pas craindre les évolutions du monde
ce nouveau monde il faut le prendre à
bras le corps
il faut continuer à y imprimer notre
marque et il faut le faire sans jamais
brader notre modèle français
ce modèle il nous ressemble et surtout
il est profondément adapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui
si bien sûr nous savons le modernisée en
permanence
nous devons poursuivre résolument dans
la voie de la réforme en faisant
toujours le choix du travail de
l'innovation et de l'esprit d'entreprise
mon troisième message c'est l'europe
lors du référendum vous avez exprimez
vos doutes vos inquiétudes vos attendent
mais il est vital de poursuivre la
construction européenne les
nationalismes qui ont fait tant de mal à
notre continent peuvent renaître à tout
moment et ce n'est pas seul que nous
ferons face aux bouleversements
économiques du monde
la france doit affirmer l'exigence d'une
europe puissance d'une europe politique
d'une europe qui garantisse notre modèle
social
c'est notre avenir qui est en jeu
portons toujours cet idéal et cette
volonté du quatrième message c'est que
la france n'est pas un pays comme les
autres elle a des responsabilités
particulières hérité de son histoire et
des valeurs universelles qu'elle a
contribué à fond j'ai ainsi face au
risque d'un choc des civilisations face
à la montée des extrémismes notamment
religieux la france doit défendre la
tolérance le dialogue et le respect
entre les hommes et entre les cultures
l'enjeu c'est la paix c'est la sécurité
du monde
de même il serait immoral et dangereux
de laisser sous l'effet d'un libéralisme
sans frein se creuser le fossé entre une
partie du monde de plus en plus riches
et des milliards d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants abandonnés à la misère et au
désespoir de voir de la france c'est de
peser de tout son poids pour que
l'économie mondiale intègre la nécessité
du développement pour tous enfin il ya
la révolution écologique qui sont les
âges
c'est nous ne parvenons pas à concilier
les besoins de croissance de l'humanité
et la souffrance d'une planète à bout de
souffle
nous courons à la catastrophe c'est une
révolution dans nos esprits tout autant
qu'à l'échelle mondiale qu'il faut mener
pour concevoir un nouveau mode de
relation avec la nature et inventer une
autre croissance avec sa recherche avec
ses entreprises avec son agriculture
avec l'avant ce qu'elle a prises dans le
nucléaire et les choix résolu qu'elle a
fait dans les énergies renouvelables la
france a tous les atouts pour relever ce
défi majeur du xxième siècle
le chat compatriotes vous l'imaginez
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion que je
m'adresse à vous ce soir
pas un instant vous n'avez cessé
d'habiter mon coeur et mon esprit
pas une minute
je n'ai cessé d'agir pour servir cette
france magnifique cette france que
j'aime autant que je vous aime cette
france riche de sa jeunesse
forte de son histoire de sa diversité
assoiffé de justice et dans vie d'agir
cette france qui croyais moi n'a pas
fini d'étonner le monde vive la
république et vive la france
[Musique]